Now let's have a little more fun by
combining operators and assignment.
Let's create a variable called
totalPayroll and set it equal to zero.
Let's also create some other
variables to hold the salaries of
three hypothetical players on,
say an athletics team.
One way we can calculate the total
payroll with salaries is to do this,
which isn't too bad,
it all fits on one line.
But in certain cases we may want
to only add one salary at a time.
And if we were to do this,
then our calculations would change
to say something like this.
In this case.
we add one salary at a time to
the existing value of total payroll.
So this isn't too bad.
If we want to add them one at a time,
but we can do better than this by
combining assignment and
the plus operator all at the same time.
And we can do this by using
the operator we want, in this case,
the addition operator
followed by an equals sign.
And while this may be
confusing at first,
let's look at how the operator
reads from left to right.
First, we want to add to our existing
value and then we want to assign.
And we can also do this with
other operators like subtraction,
multiplication, division and
the modules operator.
So go ahead and fix this up, now we got
the same value by combining the addition
and assignment for
the addition assignment operator.
If you want to see this with a different
operator, we can change all these signs
to subtraction signs and now our
total payroll is negative 2, 500,000.
And this would be more appropriate
if we wanted to show deficit
after paying our players as opposed to
the total payroll that we saw earlier.